said a lot about the role of the media
in a so-called down democracy I'm
wondering how you see the role of our
educational system what it's doing right
now what forces are driving it and what
constraints are on it and how should it
operate
well I quoted the trilateral commission
view of the educational system
namely it's a system of indoctrination
of the young and I think that's correct
it's a system of indoctrination of the
young that was the way the liberal
elites regarded and they're more or less
accurate so the educational system is
supposed to train people to be obedient
conformist not think too much which told
stay passive don't cause any crisis a
democracy don't raise any questions and
so on that's basically what the what the
system is about even the fact that the
system has a lot of stupidity in it I
think has a function you know it means
that people are filtered out for
obedience if you can guarantee lots of
stupidity in the educational system you
know like stupid assignments and things
like that you know that the only people
who make it through are people like me
and like most of you I guess who are
willing to do it no matter how stupid it
is because we'll we want to go to the
next step you know so you may know that
this assignment is idiotic and the guy
up there couldn't think his way out of a
paper bag but you'll do it anyway
because that's the way you get to the
VIX class and you want to make it and so
on and so forth well there are people
who don't do that you know there are
people who say I'm not going to do is
too ridiculous you know those people are
called behavioral problems or something
like that they end up in the principal's
office or in the streets or selling
drugs or whatever and all of this is a
technique for selection for obedience
and I have I don't have to prove this
but I have a feeling that when you go to
the elite universities you find more
obedience and conformity probably
because you're getting the students who
were better able to do it you know well
all of that is functional that's the way
it works but it and it works right
through graduate school I mean if you
Derek but how do you get the graduate
school it's already a little more
because some real contradictions develop
in the system the problem is that you
can't have progress this way you know
now especially in the sciences and
engineering that's a problem because the
corporation's
need science and engineering you know if
you don't have innovation you're really
in trouble so they have to encourage
creativity and independence because you
can't get anywhere if you just copy what
somebody told you you have to be
challenging things all the time
challenging everything you know thinking
new thoughts and so on and there you got
a real contradiction it's hard to train
people to be creative and challenging
and so on and yet to ensure that
somewhere else in their lives they're
conformist and obedient and everything
so you have problems that's a serious
problem in Japan incidentally we think
of Japan as this tremendous superpower
but that's very misleading Japan for
example it's very poor in science for
example and they're aware of it and part
of the reason is it such as part of it
it's part of the same thing that makes
them good workers obedient workers it's
a very obedient Society very deferential
and conformist Society and one effect of
that is that you you know there are real
constraints against independent fries
and thinking and you see it in the
sciences very clearly the but it's a
problem here too so there are those
contradictions when you get to graduate
school they're beginning to show up they
show up much less in the ideological
subjects because there it doesn't matter
so much if people have you know there
isn't the profits aren't made by
historians having original ideas about
the French Revolution so they can have
conventional ideas and that means that
the the pressure to try to support
innovation and freedom is much less and
the professor the pressures for
conformity on the other hand are much
greater because in the ideological
subjects it begins to be dangerous if
people think the wrong thoughts it's not
so dangerous if they have new ideas
about physics so so you but nevertheless
you know you begin to get a little flux
in the system by the time you get to
graduate school and even at lower levels
you find it I mean there's you know
there are teachers who do stimulate
thought and sometimes they get away with
it
and all the way through you know if
people are learning things you just you
just can't control you can't make them
just regurgitate what they heard now
there's a lot of pressure to turn the
schools into the Marine Corps and
there's a lot of support for it
for example there's this bestseller last
couple of years by Alan bloom that was
all over the supermarkets closing of the
American mind yeah whichever you know
huge bestseller supermarket racks which
is where I read it and things like that
well you take a look at what he's saying
it was plenty you know a lot of
enthusiastic accolades for it and so on
he was saying that a couple of smart
guys will decide what the great thoughts
are and every student will memorize them
and that's education okay well you know
I mean that's a way to turn people into
pure automata I mean even if they happen
to pick the great thoughts there is no
way less likely to get anybody to think
about those thoughts than to make that
the curriculum that finishes them off no
but and I think that's the purpose
really I mean the purpose is just to
impose Authority you know here's the
great thoughts all this other stuff is
rubbish just learn those in your okay
I'll pick them you memorize them that's
basically the line now of course that's
that's the opposite of Education that's
the way you study Talmud or something
like that but it's very popular and I
think it reflects the same concern over
the crisis of democracy that Galan was
it bloom himself was extremely the
incident that really got to him was a
case in Cornell where he was a professor
where some black students took over one
of the administer the buildings and he
was he said that's just like the Nazi
you know fak to the Nazis his old
business about the Nazis and so on and
so forth well you take a look at what
happened in that teasin tell you what he
thought the and he says the faculty
capitulated you know just like Heidegger
capitulated to the Nazis and so on what
actually happened if you look back is
that there were real grievance is
undoubtedly the
students shouldn't have done what they
did go into the building with guns and
so on but it was settled very amicably
it was settled amicably nobody was
killed the grievances were to some
extent dealt with and the net result was
better than it was before but he didn't
tell you what he thought they should
have done but it's sort of implicit I
mean I guess they should have bombed the
place or something like that but that's
what really set him off and in general
what set many people off was the you
know the the 60s are now described in
the literature as if it was a time when
students were running around burning
libraries and you know destroying the
foundations of civilization and so on
what was actually going on is they were
asking questions you know they were
raising questions they were looking into
things that people hadn't looked into
before they were not just obedient and
from the point of view of a lot of the
faculty that's equivalent to burning the
buildings they can't even that small
distinction you can't make that and this
pressure to turn the schools back to the
days when you didn't have to worry about
those things like disobedient students
asking questions about things you didn't
tell them to think about and so on